[Musik]
yoga kann alle dehnbarkeit stressabbau
beweglichkeit verbessern besserer schlaf
in der ruhr die liste ist ewig
idealerweise gehen wir dafür wohl nach
indien zu meinem bürgermeister oder
zumindest zu einem yoga lehrer hier in
deutschland aber ich bin echt ein freund
von mir sachen selbst im internet
beizubringen uns da gibt's ja auch 1000
anleitungen und tutorials außerdem kann
so ein yogakurs natürlich auch echt
teuer sein und direkt nach indien zu
ziehen ist wie die meisten dann wohl ein
bisschen zu krass also kann man sich das
auch einfach kostenlos im internet wahl
bringen welche vorteile hat es
vielleicht wenn mein körper und meine
psyche und vor allem medianwert mit yoga
lehrerin am ende dieser woche aussagen
der ich einen fortschritt zeigen wird
oder vielleicht auch gar nicht
vielleicht funktioniert das ganze im
internet sogar ziemlich gut er findet
heraus
dieses video wird unterstützt von
atletic greens was ist eigentlich yoga
medien und google zufolge hat yoga
scheinbar irgendwas mit dehnbarkeit und
frauen in leggins zu tun aber an und für
sich ist yoga eine indische
philosophische lehre die nicht
zwangsweise körperliche übungen
beinhaltet prinzipiell kann jeder weg
zur selbsterkenntnis als yoga bezeichnet
werden das was die meisten unter uns als
yoga kennen ist also eigentlich ein
kleiner rosin geprägter teil einer
hinduistischen philosophie dem viel
spiritualität weggenommen wurde
mundgerecht für den westlichen menschen
aber das ist an sich natürlich auch
überhaupt nicht schlecht ist und der
erfolg gibt diese form von yoga
schließlich auch recht und genau für
diese forderung dass die man auch im
westen kennt namens hatha yoga bei der
man versucht die balance zwischen geist
und körper durch körperliche übungen zu
finden die habe ich mich auch
entschieden auf allem weil ich der um
den meisten menschen werden sich
bestimmt cool sein wäre es mit anzusehen
wie ich am anfang total für schmerzen
aber einfach umgefallen und dann
hoffentlich immer mehr und mehr mit
meinem körper im eingang bin und dann
eine vielleicht sogar so was kann man
hätte noch träumen dürfen
ich recherchiere also was genau es mit
yoga auf sich hat und mach mir ein bild
damit wie ich am besten an die sache
herangeht es gibt unzählige yoga figuren
und von einigen habt ihr sicherlich
schon einmal gehört wie zum beispiel der
baum der cobra oder dem dreifach
verzweifelten jahre drachen im wind ok
ok den letzten habe ich mir gerade
ausgedacht ich habe mir also eine liste
mit gängigen yoga übungen gemacht und
anhand dieser werde ich meinen
fortschritt messen und diese jetzt am
anfang komplett ohne übung ausführen und
am ende meiner kurzen reise erneut der
dritte ist halt licher winkel
ich jetzt schon die nächste figur der
herabschauen der hund also das sind
jetzt erst mal leicht aus
dafür muss man die richtigen gehäuse
dass die das wird einfach jeder können
so bessere halt
also die frau geriet mit den füßen den
boden und hat den rücken gerade
deshalb jetzt dass er richtig schwierig
als nächstes die cobra okay für sie
geradeaus schritten hinten in sämtlichen
unterstützen
und eigentlich sollte jetzt mal
meine hüften am boden sein
[Musik]
der
baum fällt er
ich glaube das war ganz gut also das ist
extrem anstrengend meinem fuß in meinem
rechten bein gerade richtig schwer das
ist wirklich richtig schwer und die
balance natürlich auch super schwierig
und sind nun also die minimalen
muskelbewegungen die dafür sorgen dass
ich nicht umkippt der lotus sitzt und
ich glaube den kann ich sogar ich glaube
ich kann ich sogar ohne ende
also das ist eigentlich eine reihe von
oft so da und das ist auch nicht viel
schwieriger jetzt noch den täter über zu
machen also lotussitz ich glaube das
habe ich drauf der krieger das auch
super schwierig also ich hab hier
überhaupt nicht in den ball hinten drin
immerhin warten auch komplett gar nicht
und hier muss man jetzt auch richtig gut
aussehen können es ist noch ein sehr
weiter weg bis das alles funktioniert
meine größte schwachstelle meine
miserables dehnbarkeit ich bin gespannt
wie ich mich verbessere und ob ich am
ende die yogalehrerin beeindrucken kann
und das ist schlecht
ausgesehen training
ach sagt yoga tutorial auf youtube daran
schade dass jetzt einfach da einfach
daran dass nicht geld ja ja das war es
von diesem video yoga lernen im internet
yoga lernen für anfänger 20 minuten home
work out das bin ich doch
reinhard mohn preislich schultern über
vorne hoch zu den ohren das kannst du
doch gar nicht so gut
ja genau die wollen sich dem himmel aber
können sie nicht
[Musik]
ausatmung schieb dich nach hinten oder
absurde hinkriegt
das sieht es bei mir nicht so elegant
aus ich finde es ist schwer einen klaren
pfad zu finden was yoga angeht beim
kraftsport zum beispiel gibt es
zumindest einen grob vorgegebenen
aktionsplan den man als anfänger folgen
kann um sein ziel zu erreichen aber beim
yoga womöglich liegt es daran dass beim
yoga tatsächlich eher der weg das
eigentliche ziel ist und es keine klare
endstation gibt
es ist so schwierig hatte
[Musik]
war das schon eine ganz andere richtung
wie ihre füße
moment
das hat gut getan also kanada wo so hart
gezogen hat krempel der sonst so richtig
entspannt man spürt sein körper dann
aber war schon richtig gut auf eine
angenehme art und weise
ich habe mir jetzt übrigens noch
passende klamotten kauft keine angst
hand in hautenge leggins eigentlich eher
das gegenteil relativ lockere kleinen
gewandt ich denke nicht dass man sowas
braucht aber hey beim kater oder so das
macht man ja auch nicht einfach nur toll
in große und ich bin jetzt einfach mal
offen dafür vielleicht versetzt person
gewand irgendwie eine spezielle stimmung
oder so trennt sie
anschließend mache ich den übungen damit
ich diesmal für die yoga figuren etwas
vorbereitet bin das auto tier ist
übrigens super bequem es ist etwas
billig geschnitten und der stoff könnt
ihr auch besser sein aber optisch finde
ich eigentlich ganz cool frisch gedehnt
geht es dann erneut an meine sechs
figuren vom anfang und vor allem der
seitlich gedehnte winkel gefällt mir
hier schon recht recht gut
[Musik]
also die krähe sind natürlich auch
zunehmend nicht bilder aus
also eigentlich könnte man in der
position auch direkt in anstand gehen
eigentlich genug herumgealbert weiter
geht es mit einem weiteren trainings
video aus dem internet
[Musik]
im heutigen anleitung video wurden neben
dem körperlichen aspekt auch sehr stark
die innere ruhe gefühle und der eigene
atem thematisiert yoga szene scheint
also echt bei weitem nicht so
oberflächlich wie man es als
außenstehender annehmen könnte
[Musik]
die letzte training session vor dem
großen finale hat gestartet es ist
wieder einmal gleichzeitig totale
körperspannung aber auch geistige
entspannung pur und dann ist mir
eingefallen dass sophies tante auch
online yogakurse macht also dachte ich
mir schon mal vorbei was dieser auf
instagram kostet uns na ja also mir
sieht das aus weniger die versucht sich
zu befreien ich bin jetzt zum ersten mal
eben in einem richtigen yoga studio und
nehme jetzt quasi auf die probe gestellt
ob das was ich jetzt gemacht habe
überhaupt irgendwie anderen fuß hatte
oder halt nicht die person die das
beurteilt wird ist rabea von logician
scoach in köln ja genau auch sie machte
aber zuletzt in kassel jogi würde der
das auf der yogamatte machen oder nicht
zb auffängt und das erste ist der
gedrehte seitliche winkel und es ist
wirklichkeit nicht umzufallen das ist
wirklich
dass wir noch gut hat mir mal einen kopf
ohne noch um und dann in der ausatmung
lehne ich ein bisschen vor mit dem
oberkörper und dreh dich nach rechts
ok wenn es nicht atmen kann es ist das
nicht eine übung übrigens gucken wir das
gut ab ich will aber dir doch mal
zunächst ein bisschen leichteren übungen
versuch mal für dich lang zu strecken
und dann schiebt so langsam finden und
da ist schon wieder nicht so also das
ist für absolute anfänger geeignet
theoretischen das ist ja wahr
das wäre schon die kobra in der du
bestimmt auch von wartung zu gut bleiben
kann das wäre die coba die wie steht die
weder baum und da fühle ich mich jetzt
ziemlich konstant dass ich glaubte das
gericht glaube ich ganz gut hin
jakub mal mega das ist ein 1 1 baum also
ich jetzt hier noch als tipp damit auf
dem weg gehen würde es wieder atmen
das super schön ist ist das dein fuß
hier richtig cool arbeitet merkst du das
liest erarbeitet und wackelt wenn du
jetzt mal versucht den großen zeh ball
mehr in den boden zu acht mal richtig
großen und kleinen tun dann kriegst du
noch mal so eine richtige sind pushen
und innigste lotussitz bin konnte ich
halt eigentlich irgendwie schon immer
ach komm sollen im problem für mich acht
einsätze und damit hast du eigentlich
schon das was all die anderen übungen
tun sollen denn du hast mit stabilen
umsätzen nur aus dem grund machen
eigentlich sogar dafür sitzen könnten
westbalkans für das meditieren ist das
jetzt hier sowohl der selbst als auch
der ganze oberschenkel und knie am boden
sind da kommen einem schon zu dem punkt
dass scheinbar mehr auf das spirituelle
aspekt eingegangen wird also sowohl im
internet als auch jetzt quasi hier weil
ich dachte eigentlich dass yoga sowie es
indessen praktiziert wird eigentlich nur
mit glorifizierte den übungen sind aber
das den eindruck man jetzt komm ich
finde man muss halt auf einer art und
weise verpacken je nachdem ob du grad
ein anfängerkurs
ich sitze was ich mir vorgenommen habe
wurde krieges lassen wir die arme wieder
sinken bitte und was du als erstes maß
ist er immer den hinteren fuß zum boden
und zwar parallel als die ferse ach ja
wenn du den offenen krieger wenn du
diesen krieger gemacht dass die leute
jetzt irgendwie einer schwierigste
yogaübungen er war so
[Musik]
schon krass ich finde ich jetzt
letztendlich eigentlich falsch gemacht
haben also ich dachte das schon wirklich
nicht dass ich besonders gut bin aber
jetzt weiß ich dass ich einfach noch
schlechter wenn ich finde das richtig
bock gemacht ich spüre überall so ein
bisschen meine muskeln einfach durch
musste auch natürlich ein bisschen
gerade ist das gefühlte yoga war super
entspannt halber auch wirklich einfach
einfach nur spaß gemacht wird eine sache
die mich überrascht hat ist das obwohl
ich ja eigentlich auch meditieren und es
mir relativ leicht fällt in seinen
zustand zu kommen wo ich mich eins mit
dem universum fühlt heißt das bei yoga
überhaupt nicht war viel zu konzentriert
damit nicht im jung zu kippen und die
übungen halbwegs richtig zu machen ich
denke das kommt damit derzeit entspannt
war es bisher aber auf ein für alle mal
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich
ein bisschen beweglicher geworden bin so
bewegungen im alltag die von mir echt
alle ein stück war leichter ich habe
also wirklich vorstellen das ganze
einmal weiterzumachen aber nicht nur
körperliche betätigung ist wichtig für
seine gesundheit sondern auch die
ernährung vitamine mineralstoffe
antioxidantien wichtige enzyme und so
weiter kann man zwar theoretisch
ausreichend über seine reguläre mal zur
aufnehmen in der praxis klappt das aber
meistens nicht mit ashley greenes
unserem heutigen sponsor passiert das
aber fast von selbst erklärt kriens
beinhaltet 75 vitamine mineralstoffe mit
komplexer und weitere inhaltsstoff wird
die alle aus rein natürlichen
lebensmitteln gewonnen werden das heißt
alles was in diesem pulver drin ist ist
vegan und kommt direkt aus der natur
also aus einem echten pilz einer echten
wurzel einer echten fotos und so weiter
man muss sich dabei auch keine gedanken
machen wie viel man jetzt von welchen
nährstoffen soll mit der kleine prinz
ist alles abgedeckt und alle zutaten
sind perfekt aufeinander abgestimmt für
den optimalen schlaf verdauung energie
und ein gesundes immunsystem alles aus
ihr machen müsst es eins von diesen
mitgelieferten daily päckchen oder ein
löffel aus der großen packung in eurer
mitgelieferten flasche mit masse zu
mischen
und fertig
felix ist eine zweite portion ich mache
das am liebsten täglich nach dem
aufstehen und sogar richtig lecker liegt
jetzt auf atletic kriens punkt kommt
omar jedem einer zuschauerin zu der
bestellung ein jahresvorrat an vitamin
d3 und fünf praktischen travel pack
kostenlos dazu gelegt wenn euch das
video gefallen hat abonniert gern diesen
kanal ist kommt fast jede woche eines
dieser experimente und da würde ich
sagen sehen uns am nächsten wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]